on the mound for the rangers today will
be the right-hander from the university
of florida dane dunning he is two and
three with a 434 era
but mayhew a right-handed batter stands
in
here's the pitch and there's a hot shot
up the middle backhanded by solac behind
the bag throws to first and he got him
nice play by nick solak and here is
brett gardner
gardner hitting 184 no homers and three
runs batted in rangers go into the
overshift of the one-two count on
gardner
and the pitch he struck him out swinging
fastball at 93. domingo hermann the
right-hander from san pedro de macari in
the dominican republic he has a three
and two record and a 3.62 earned run
average here's nick solak getting 265.
eight homers and 21 runs batted in
this one on the ground into right field
base hit solac is on
and the rangers
have their first hit of the ball game
well two down here is um
joey gallo
gallo it's 211 seven homeless 21 rbis
now here's the one two
and harmon deals struck him out swinging
fastball away at 93.
so
in the inning no runs one hit
and one left will be hitting 182 four
homer's 11 runs padded in
2-2 pitch strike three call down goes
rookie
fastball in the inside corner at 91.
gary sanchez coming up here's the one
two there's a chopper speared by dunning
above his cap
to second for one to first a double play
one four three dunny's back was turned
to the hitter and somehow he was able to
reach up and snag that high hopper
behind his head
what a play
the double play ends the inning after
one and a half were
scoreless yankees have runners at first
and second
with nobody out now for tyler wade
and he takes strike three call third
strikeout for dunning
le mayhew grounded out on a ball hit up
the middle to get the game started
forward at second and first one out here
in the top of the third lego two
is hit sharply to first backhanded by
low he goes to keiner for leftover for
one and that's it is he throws to third
and they've got him at third what a play
by isaiah tyner falefa as he throws in
behind mike ford who had taken two steps
beyond third and he gets picked off for
the final out of the inning
[Applause]
well we go to the bottom of the third on
the first pitch
heim pops it up behind the plate and
reaching back as sanchez to make the
catch he he overran it which is easy to
do it's like the ball goes up the
elevator shaft
and so sanchez at the last moment
lurched backward
to make the catch one pitch one out and
here is
the two hitter nick solac
02 to solac
now harman will deal o2 struck him out
swinging 96 mile an hour heater right
under the hands a heck of a pitch
and it brings nate low to the plate
low who flied out to end ohio in the
left field corner his first time up
here's the two one to low
and the pitch is hit in the air to
center
gardner comes in to make the catch and
end the inning
no runs one hit one left at the end of
three no score brings up rugi
as this pitch is on the inside corner
for a called third strike
same pitch that dunning threw to strike
out odor in the second he throws here at
three and two and rugi is the second out
in the inning
and it brings up glaiber torres torres
who singled
out into left center his first time
the 1-1
that ball hit sharply to short but
scooped up by connor falefa he sets and
throws and we're done here in the fourth
inning so the yankees get a lead off
double from gardner but they don't make
it count
no runs one hit one left three and a
half complete it remains nothing nothing
and so the
rangers have first and second knowing
out
well here's a left-handed david dahl
who singled his first time up
gallow leads off second garcia leads off
first
now domingo will deal 3-2
struck him out swinging that's something
that was a change well here is
kiner falefa isaiah keiner
velepha
now the
the shortstop
alrighty hitting shorts up digs back in
it'll be a 3-2
as runners lead first and second with
one out the pitch is hit on the ground
to third lemayo goes the second one on
the first double play
a five four three double play a very
good turn by odor at second
so the double play ends the inning no
runs two hits one left
and at the end of
four innings of play no score top of the
fifth gary sanchez to get it started
and he takes strike three call
sanchez down looking for the first out
of the fifth inning
with two away and the game still
scoreless miguel and duhar is coming up
dunning pushes off comes home and
there's a call strike three
got him on a fast ball away that's a
half a dozen punch-outs for dunning he's
had as many as 10 in the game
and we're going to the bottom of the
fifth scoreless rangers and yankees
here's nick solak who has singled and
struck out he's a right-hand hitter
the pitch to soloq is grounded to third
backhanded by the mayor goes to second
for the fourth what a play what a play
by lemayo
it was a chopper headed down the line he
backhanded it and turned
and he was on a knee and he turned and
threw perfect strike duo door just
nipped the basement here's joey gallo
gallo is one for two
so here is a 3-2 pitch
to gallow with one out of no one on and
the pitch caught on him is he struck
about swinging
garcia has flied out and singled he's a
right-hand hitter the o2 struck him out
swinging change
strikeout number five for harman
they're gonna send up urshella
so a shella hits for ford
oh here's the 2-0 coming
and geo swings and lines one to right
field there is a base hit
scoring is odor
stopping at second
is sanchez it's a base hit and an rbi
geo comes through again he comes through
so often and the yankees take a
one-nothing lead
now here is aaron judge
and he's going to come up and hit for
tyler wade i'll tell you one thing about
pinch hitting michael the best thing
that can happen is you see a couple
pitches
and you're not in a hole oh two so this
is a good spot for aaron judge base hit
up the middle
sanchez rounds third he will score
the throw is two-third and they have
urshella who tried to get back to second
and he's saying that he's safe
nonetheless the first pinch hit in aaron
judge's career it's a pinch hit single
and the yankees lead two nothing and
we'll see what they say with the play at
second
batter one for three with a single
one ball two strikes
the pitch
straight three call
frozen with a slider
torrez is out and so are the yankees
no runs one hit and two men left
and they will send up chris davis
to pinch it for dahl
here comes the 2-2 from chapman
and the pitch struck him out swinging
ball game over yankees win the
yankees
win